man real-estate is hot in most cities
right now
I mean white-hot it's selling some
places a house goes on the market it
doesn't last 24 hours and has multiple
offers now if I'm selling something and
I saw it in 24 hours and I have multiple
offers that might tell me I sold it too
cheap I would be tempted to price it up
and not have multiple offers in 24 hours
I'd be tempted to leave some more chips
on the table you know I'm saying that I
want to take some more off the table I
guess is what I'm saying I want to want
to pocket some more of this money if
there's markets hot it's a delicate
balance you want to sell the house you
don't want to list it just in crazy zone
you don't be that seller but on the
other hand I really prefer something to
last
I sold a piece of property recently and
it didn't last a week and I had three
full price offers immediately it goes
through my mind I didn't sell it for
enough I took the offer it's gone but I
mean you know I always wonder and so
here's what you have to have in a market
like this the problem is any monkey can
sell a house in a market like this and
and real estate license are so easy to
get that sometimes people that get them
are monkeys you know I'm saying they're
nice smarter than a monkey that I mean a
monkey can just put us on the yard right
and so you don't want a monkey selling
your house this is your largest most
expensive asset for most of you you want
to get the most you can possibly get out
of it in a white hot steamy market just
because the markets hot doesn't mean you
can't make mistakes you can make huge
mistakes and so you don't want you know
somebody who's had a license for three
weeks selling your house I'm sorry for
those of you that have been in the
business for three weeks but I was in
the business for three weeks once back
in 1978 and you didn't want me selling
your house then you want a pro selling
your house and I was not a pro in 1978
three weeks after I got my license so
you know you want the best and you want
the best getting the most you can get
out of your
and still selling it in a very short
period of time and you got to really be
on top of things in this world right now
to do that
so the endorsed local provider program
connects you with three top real estate
professionals in your area minimum so
when you click on ELP for real estate
you're gonna get a high-octane high
protein somebody that sells a bazillion
houses in your area
no newbies nobody that just started
sorry to you people are just starting
but you're not gonna be in the ELP
program after you go sell 50 60 houses a
year for a couple years we'll talk to
you but we don't want to send out listen
I'm taking care of my listener I want
you guys our listeners to get the best
possible real estate experience that you
can get and and you know just because a
house sells fast doesn't mean you're
gonna have a great experience you have
somebody knows how to walk them through
the closing walk through the appraisal
process make sure to start with that the
stupid house is priced at properly
enough I mean you don't want to over
price and go crazy land but in this
market don't under price it either you
know using using data from six months
ago to sell a house right now is a
really dumb idea in most markets the
houses going up a lot during the last
six months so get a pro I mean listen if
you are doing some little minor non and
non-invasive surgery you don't worry
about it
but if you got some big major brain
surgery thing you want the top brain
surgeon right and this is a brain
surgery I mean this is a big deal it's
the largest thing you own you make a ten
percent mistake on a two hundred
thousand dollar transaction that's known
as twenty thousand dollars I don't know
what neighborhood you grew up in
neighborhood up when we grew up and we
called that a lot of money don't make a
mistake like that by screwing around
with somebody that they're well-meaning
but I'm not saying they're con artists
and a con artist but you don't get
screwed by con artists you get screwed
by well-meaning ignoramuses enthusiastic
well-meaning ignoramuses and that's what
I was three weeks after I got my real
estate license I was enthusiastic
I was well-meaning I had your best
interest at heart but I was
doofus I didn't know what I was doing I
had no experience handling your largest
asset that's crazy land don't do that
stuff Dave Ramsey calm if you're getting
ready to list a house list it with
somebody knows what the flip they're
doing okay seriously something to think
about